le secrétaire d'état chargé du budget
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
christian eckert
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation donc de preuves par 3 sur
public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse à un moment d'extrême
tension sociale et politique tension
également sur les économies qu'il vous
faut trouver sur le budget au cours de
cette émission et bien vous répondrez à
trois grandes questions premièrement est
ce que la cgt finalement aura la peau de
la loi travail et partant peut-être du
gouvernement deuxième question telle and
oracle de bercy est-ce que vous allez
nous annoncer une baisse des impôts elle
est espéré dans le sépare les français
également par françois hollande mais
vous connaissez la difficulté de trouver
des marges de manoeuvre et c'est de cela
que dépend cette baisse des impôts pour
2010 est enfin troisième question alors
que les maires se réunissent en congrès
à la fin du mois est ce que vous allez
enfin entendre leur sos de droite comme
de gauche vous le savez les élus
comptent est votre vision de leur
situation financière
françois hollande et manuel valls à
l'unisson face au mouvement de grève et
au blocage qui se multiplient en france
un seul mot d'ordre la fermeté on écoute
le chef de l'état ça ne mérite pas le
une forme de respect par rapport à ceux
qui ont des revendications légitimes
mais ça ne me convient pas non plus à
accepter ce qui est aujourd'hui un
blocage qui est fondée simplement par
une stratégie portée par une minorité
voilà un blocage est aujourd'hui une
confrontation brutale la cgt
finira-t-elle par avoir la peau de la
loi travail
je voudrais vraiment réussir le forme de
votre question parce qu'avoir la pause
qu'est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui dans nos
gouvernements uniquement mobile et par
l'idée d'avoir la peau de quelqu'un ou
de sauver sa propre peau quand on est en
responsabilité au gouvernement de voir
cette faire en sorte que les conditions
économiques les conditions budgétaires
et conditions sociales permettent au
pays de progresser
il s'agit pas d'avoir la peau de l'un la
peau de l'autre
je crois qu'il faisait un mauvais renvoi
à l'ambition qu'elle venait de rappeler
mais une forme d'apaisement dans le
débat le débat il a eu lieu
vif il a même eu lieu un peu à
l'assemblée jean temps j'entends dire
que le 49-3 aurait interrompu empêcher
toute forme de débat
g des travaux en commissions et des
débuts de travaux dans l'hémicycle
puisse être reprendre ils vont reprendre
au sénat puis ensuite à l'assemblée ait
eu des discussions il ya eu des
amodiations de la loi des aménagements
de la loi
alors certains disent qu'on a vidé la
loi de sa substance d'autres disent mais
non ça reste une loi extrêmement
pénalisante
j'allais dire c'est peut-être aussi le
signe qu'on est dans une espèce de
légume est alors l'apaisement
l'apaisement vous appeler à l'apaisement
que peut faire le gouvernement
au début on pense d'abord que il faut
que les organisations syndicales devant
la cgt mais pas que la cgt et prennent
leurs responsabilités la responsabilité
c'est qu'au moment où au moment où la
croissance s'améliorent ce que confirme
aujourd'hui le fmi le fmi vient vient
effectivement de relever sa prévision de
croissance
il était à pains nous nous avons posé
comme hypothèse 1.5 pour de l'excellent
mais alors aujourd'hui le fait me dit
oui on aura une croissance en france de
près de 1 à l'importation elle dit
qu'elle prend ses responsabilités en
bloquant mais justement je pense qu'au
moment où la croissance reprend de façon
plutôt significative toujours espérer
mieux
c'est un mauvais coup qui peut être
porté à l'économie des journées grève
des journées de frilosité dans le monde
du travail dans les déplacements
c'est traditionnel ça ne l'est déjà un
mauvais oui donc il est temps d'en
sortir et vous l'avez déjà chiffré ses
mauvais coups pour l'économie honorons
non mais pour l'instant il est bien sûr
trop tôt pour en parler mais vous savez
que tous les élus tous les événements
qui se passent en france aussi un
retentissement sur l'attractivité de
notre pays que ce soit en matière
économique sont en matière touristique
et je pense qu'il est temps maintenant
d'en sortir mais c'est pas du tout la
voie qu'emprunte la série tv vous avez
vu la multiplication des blocages
l'appelle maintenant même à la grève
reconductible à la sncf à la fin du mois
oui une forme un peu de de dispersion en
lançant un mouvement reconductible à la
sncf on annonce une grève à la ratp
on a ces blocages dans les raffineries
dans les dépôts de carburant
je crois qu'il ya là une attitude que
les français d'ailleurs commence un
petit peu à mal le recevoir
vous attendez une condamnation des
français ceux qui se lèvent le matin qui
convient et qui parie sur l'avenir pour
reprendre les expressions des manuels
macro non évitons les mots qui blessent
les mots qui vexe peine le ministre
condamne avions prise en otage je n'aime
pas ce vocabulaire
je n'aime pas trop quelle heure il
s'agit que chacun dans une situation qui
est difficile d'être sûr économique et
social qui est tendu vous l'avez dit il
s'agit un moment donné de dire écoutez
remettons ce pays en marche
c'est ce que nous faisons avec
responsabilité ont en posant sa nombre
de principes dans la loi qui peuvent
changer l'état d'esprit qui peuvent
parfois interpellé ont souvent été mal
présentée d'ailleurs souvent caricaturée
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont en
train d'en prendre conscience et vous
aviez en face de voir plutôt que moi
philippe martinez le leader de la cgt
que lui diriez vous je veux dire est que
il ya eu des évolutions que il a
probablement lui un peu trop vite les
propositions qui sont contenues dans le
projet de loi et qu'il est temps
maintenant de de sortir par le haut de
cette difficulté parce que sinon il ya
un risque économique effectivement c'est
quand l'économie va mal c'est finalement
un risque social qui se concrétise et
des difficultés souvent pour les gens du
plus modeste à l'heure même si vous
rejetez vous l'avez dit d'emblée l'idée
d'un passage en force
cette loi travail lui le patron de la
cgt dénonce un déni de démocratie
il rappelle que cette loi n'était pas au
programme de françois hollande en 2009
100 ha en 2000 dans 1101 2012 en écoute
là monsieur martinez le gouvernement et
le premier ministre en particulier joue
un jeu dangereux
essayez diviser la cgt essayer de vous
poser la cgt aux citoyens essayer
d'opposer la cgt aux salariés qui je
préviens tout de suite le gouvernement
attention à ne pas s'opposer au droit de
grève c'est une décision de
l'organisation internationale du travail
nous sommes déterminés à aller jusqu'au
bout en tout cas nous nous appelons à
une généralisation des grèves partout
dans tous les styles variés
alors c'est pas l'appel à la
responsabilité là un cas vous espérez
donc bien sûr mais pour répondre à votre
question sur l'exercice de la démocratie
et des droits de grêle vous avez entendu
la démocratie à la son rythme à la son
calendrier
elle pose des échéances à le confier à
un moment donné l'exercice du pouvoir
pour des durées limitées
avec forcément une délégation d'exercice
du pouvoir au nom du peuple français à
ses gouvernants ça n'autorise pas tout
et n'importe quoi mais je crois que ces
présidents qui disait ça l'autre jour
sur une grande radio à matin est ce que
au moment de l'élection présidentielle
on pouvait anticiper ce qui se passe sur
le terrorisme par exemple ou sur des
questions internationales lourde qui se
sont posés à lui quelques mois quelques
années après son arrivée la loi travail
c'est pas une réaction à l'actualité et
dramatique là c'est un programme et je
crois qu'elle est issue d'une prise de
conscience très forte du manque de
compétitivité de notre pays de nos
entreprises
on l'a vu faire intervenue après 2000
dont la vue sur les questions des marges
des entreprises nous avons restauré les
masses une entreprise je pense que on en
reparlera peut-être dans cette émission
oui c'était important c'est est
essentiel aujourd'hui les grandes
entreprise ces observateurs de la vie
économique internationale reproche à la
france non plus le manque de marge aux
entreprises encore plus tellement la
question de la fiscalité qui reste un
problème mais qui s'est estompée au en
tout cas qui a diminué d'intensité suite
aux mesures que nous avons prises et le
principal argument qui est mise en avant
par les investisseurs internationaux
c'est la question du marché du travail
et des contraintes qu'il impose et qui
ne sont pas les mêmes dans la nuit voire
de l'europe du fmi puisque on l'évoquait
il ya un instant qui par ailleurs
aujourd'hui dans sa note ainsi que la
france allait encore plus loin que la
loi elle comme brille donc il faudra
aller plus loin j'ai rencontré la
délégation du fmi qui lorsqu'il vient en
france rencontre beaucoup d'acteurs
entre autres je les ai vus ont
effectivement ont dit qu'ils allaient
relever la prévision de croissance mais
on a évoqué aussi ces questions de
marché du travail qui sont une
préoccupation
on dit parfois que c'est bruxelles qui
préoccupe et qui donne des injonctions
et c'est pas bruxelles seulement c'est
aussi le fmi mme c et vous avez raison
il a raison siens constat contenu dans
un monde concurrentiel dans une
concurrence internationale
m on peut être contre c'est une réalité
d'aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que la
loi travail n'est qu'une étape
il ya eu enfin n'a présenté de la loi
macron la loi un croissance activité
comme étant une première étape on a
présenté la loi travail quitte
aujourd'hui devant le parlement comme
une deuxième étape
prenons les choses comme elles comme
ferrer n aujourd'hui c'est une étape en
tout cas comme un événement et des spas
déjà le ministre dit des nominee
franchir leurs collègues de mercier même
à condé dans les échos ce matin qu'il
faudra aller plus loin par exemple aussi
négocié au niveau des entreprises des
salaires écoutez bien président et un
premier ministre
il se trouve l'économie est un acteur
parmi d'autres au sein du gouvernement
ou bien on en reparlera 1
parce que j'entends vos réserves est ce
qu'il faut aller jusqu à réquisitionner
le personnel dans certaines raffineries
pour que la france ne soit pas à sec
on apprécie la situation propre à
l'exclu presque au jour le jour
moi je n'exclus rien j'étais aujourd'hui
en province avant tout rejoindre
discuter avec le le préfet aujourd'hui
on a aussi un phénomène pardon rentrer
dans ses dents c'est ce qui peut
apparaître comme des détails c'est que
les gens devance le risque de pénurie
stock carburant qu'on a on a finalement
un phénomène qui rajoute de la pénurie à
skippeuse qui peut manquer dans les
dépôts de carburants ont aussi été
déposés stratégie qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre en cas de besoin
tout ça est géré par les ministres
concernés alors vous avez évoqué
l'attractivité de la france qui est en
recul sur terre
selon certaines études et il ya quelques
heures le pdg de total monsieur puyané a
dit que sa société et bien menacé de
réviser ses investissements en france en
raison de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans ses raffineries comment est-ce que
vous réagissez à cette annonce et cette
menace
total est une société multinationale qui
a l'habitude de dispatcher dispatcher
prend dans ses investissements au
travers et mandant comprend beaucoup
environ source pétrolière en fonction
des besoins en fonction des capacités
techniques de raffinage notamment c'est
pas nouveau que total adapte
l'australie elle a souvent fait des
adaptations de ses stratégies
économiques pour des raisons fiscales
elles étaient reprochés d'ailleurs juste
titre je regarde un peu changé de
position donc essayons là encore de
retrouver un peu le sens du dialogue de
la sérénité totale est une grande
multinationale d'origine française donc
totale est une grande entreprise ou
l'état aussi parfois un rôle à jouer
mais quand son pdg dit qu'ils les
fassent aujourd'hui à une forme de
rupture entre son entreprise et ses
salariés qui bloquent les raffineries
vous l'entendez vous le comprenez pas
sur la majorité en tous cas la totalité
des salariés qu'ils attribuent à
l'horizon du diamant nombreux pour
gagner q tec encore qu'on connaît oui on
voit les difficultés qu'on arrive à
lever je crois qu'il ya surtout de deux
raffineries créer évacués par les forces
sont sans grand incident pour l'instant
facebook que tout ça aussi dur parce que
y'a aussi des violences il ya des
blocages qui pénalise l'économie ou où
la vie des gens mais il ya aussi des
formes de violence qui sont nés six
gagnants conforme de la rupture si on
élargit entre la cgt aujourd'hui à du
pacte entre la cgt et le pays
tu suis pas sûr que le sujet était signé
un pacte avec le pays
c'est par une saignée absolument et
patras et la cgt n'est quand même pas le
seul la seule organisation syndicale de
ce pays à son nombre d'organisations
syndicales qui se sont inscrits dans des
démarches différentes de ceux le sais
j'étais alors en entendez votre appel à
l'apaisement mais certains estiment que
la radicalisation actuelle découle de la
déception du pouvoir de gauche depuis
l'élection de françois hollande je vous
propose d'écouter jean luc mélenchon qui
a encore haussé le ton tout à l'heure ça
suffit du gouvernement maintenant jeudi
à valls et hollande c'est bon quoi
il arrêté parce qu'il y en a c'est pas
la peine d'aller faire des
gesticulations sur jaurès et le reste
est de dire au secours la droite de
revient est de faire pire que tout ce
qu'on a jamais vu dans ce pays en
matière de brutalité sociale de loi
injuste et de persécutions contre les
travailleurs jamais personne
au cours des 15 dernières années n'a
parlé à la cgt et à force ouvrière comme
vous êtes en train de le faire mais qui
vous aide pour vous permettre ça qui
vous a élu quel est votre famille
politique que d'autre que vous le fasse
on pourrait le comprendre
après tout ce serait dans l'ordre de la
polémique démocratique mais vous vous
n'avez pas le droit de parler comme ça
valls et hollande qui vous êtes pour qui
vous prenez vous qui vous êtes
lance jean luc mélenchon que lui
répondez vous l'enfant est habitué des
formules des formules leur vous dites
qu'ils haussent le ton fric avant
j'arrive à rémalard haussé le ton la
bascule et il est un peu à fond moi je
crois qu'il faut dire clairement les
choses aux français nous avons un pays
qui a pris du retard en matière de
compétitivité
peut-être ne l'at-on pas suffisamment
mesuré dans un seau nombre de deux
circonstances où c'est les élections
sont souvent propres aussi à faire de la
surenchère à faire parfois dé prendre
parfois des engagements pas toujours
suffisamment mesuré trois quarts n'a de
nom mais que tu ailles à un journal du
soir qui a récemment fait part d'un
certain nombre d'analystes d'anciens
ministres du gouvernement
je crois qu'il y avait surtout il y
avait surtout ce sentiment de dire que
tu es on a découvert une situation qui
était finalement plus grave que celle
qu'on a qu'on avait parait compliqué
surtout la mesure de gauche s'étaient
enfin moi je suis pas trouvé que m
enfin on note pas la même lecture un
seul élu attentivement parce que oui je
trouve que je les connais pour certains
d'entre eux très personnellement donc ça
vous apparaissez intérêts voire les
c'est ce qui m'a ce qui m'a surpris sur
l'opportunité de ce type de déclarations
à un moment où les tensions sont fortes
mais en tout cas sur le fond moi je
comprends ces déclarations j'aurais pu
la lui même un certain moment mais
apprécié de venir écouter on a tous
découvert des choses qui n'étaient pas
forcément connu l'ampleur des déficits
les impasse budgétaire pour ramener un
domaine que je connais
les questions fiscales les difficultés
de certaines administrations les impasse
budgétaire qui avait été fait
ça faisait quand même énormément alors
pression souvenez vous la pression
l'euro dont l'avenir était incertain la
pression de bruxelles
non non ça fait quand même temps on n'a
pas vu ce type de situation avait été
victime de ce que vous avez découvert à
propos de mélenchon lundi encore que le
gouvernement là et qui êtes-vous
lance-t-il veut créer le désordre pour
se présenter ensuite en sauveur qu'est
ce que vous pensez du joli nom il va on
n'est pas dans ce type de stratégie
quand on est responsable on est au
gouvernement on ne joue pas avec le pays
on ne joue pas des stratégies qui
seraient des stratégies électorales si
nous n'avions qu'une stratégie
électorale qu'à l'intérieur
quel intérêt pardon aurions nous à
prendre des mesures dont on mesure
parfois la difficulté pour nos
compatriotes alors comprendre les
critiques de droite maintenant élevé
surtout un pouvoir qui a entravé qui est
disqualifié comme le dit alain juppé en
écoute l'ancien premier ministre
gouvernement s'est lui dans un bruit pas
en engageant une réforme
par annonceur copier ce que je vais dire
à voix des électeurs séparément
d'inspecter le trouble profond
aujourd'hui à la fois de jeux vidéo
et du parlement tout apprendre
le show qui travaillent et qui ont
besoin de s'alimenter naissance n'a
vraiment
je rappe idée fication prise suffit pas
d'annoncer ont fait à la gp10 que les
électeurs n'ont pas voté à gauche pour
avoir cette politique
il est quand même qu des soeurs je crois
qu'il a connu lorsqu'il était prévu nice
de ce pays
à ce nombre de situations qu'on peut au
moins dire comparables je suis pas sûr
que lui aussi s'était engagé à apporter
des textes qui l'a finalement d'ailleurs
retiré lorsqu'il a été premier ministre
pour qu'un peu là aussi de
responsabilités d'humidité devant une
situation qu'il faut affronter
courageusement gouvernement le fait
courageusement premier ministre a
clairement indiqué les choses qu'elle
était sa volonté d'aboutir et la
différence donc entre manuel valls et
alain juppé sait que le premier ministre
actuel tiendra bon on ne le confirmer ce
soir au château différence
ah oui mais celle ci a je pense que le
promu istres est parfaitement déterminé
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas dû rentrer un
peu plus tôt et d'israël
il était en israël alors que la crise
couve et s'amplifier dans notre pays
tu le dit lui-même les moyens modernes
de communication et de gestion
permettent aujourd'hui de faire des
choses parfois à distance si je crois
qu'il ait pris un engagement avait
d'ailleurs une situation avec israël
kim a été d'être clarifiés je crois
suite un certain nombre de votes et de
décision il était utile aussi parce que
ça aussi son importance la politique
internationale alors deuxième partie
maintenant de preuve par trois khristian
kara vert avec lucile malandain de l'
agence france-presse
c'est cette question est ce que vous
êtes favorable à une baisse des impôts
et l'espère et je le disais par les
français mais également par françois
hollande la question semble farfelu au
moment où vous relancer à bercy le
processus d'économies à tout va les
critiques de l'opposition par la voix
d'albert eric de montgolfier rapporteur
général
les républicains de la commission des
finances du sénat est ce qui est assez
paradoxal c'est que le parlement comme
vous savez voc loi de finances en
décembre et la de finances rectificatif
à décembre et quelques semaines après le
vote du parlement et bien le présent la
république annonce des mesures pour plus
d'un milliard sur plan de l'emploi plus
des mesures sur les écluses
heures plus des mesures nouvelles tous
les jours et certains de plus de 4
milliards d'euros et ça pose la question
de la sincérité d'un budget qui est très
largement modifié par les annonces de
l'exécutif
et ces annonces ne sont évidemment pas
financé et en tous les cas soit de la
prévisibilité parfois parce que la
question du rôle de l'emploi c'est
certaine urgence mais c'est pas quelque
chose qui on découvre du jour au
lendemain je vous rappelle qu'on est
passé à plus de 2000 milliards d'euros
de dette
et puis on est le seul pays on a vu dans
l'union européenne
le seul pays peut-être la croatie qui
laisse filer son déficit alors que les
autres pays ont fait des efforts
drastiques et en tous les cas on le
risque évidemment c'est qu'on s'éloigne
pour financer notamment à saddam
d'annonce à la prochaine présidentielle
voilà pourquoi qu'il a un instant par
quentin calme et bonsoir laisser malanda
alors vos questions cela paraît pas au
budget alors mac est ma première
question c'est allez vous annoncer une
baisse d'impôts comme le souhaite le
président de la cli consolante qui en a
déjà parlé plusieurs fois pour 2010 est
bien tu en paies temps je faire deux
préalables
le premier c'est que vous avez tout à
l'heure présenté comme un oracle de
bercy je n'aurais pas cette prétention
j'y reviendrai dans un instant la
deuxième c'est ce que dit le rapporteur
général du budget au sénat
c'est choquant sur la sincérité non ce
qui est choquant c'est qui dit on est le
seul pays qui laisse filer les déficits
les déficits publics a baissé sans
interruption depuis 2012 il était à 5,1
pour cent
il est aujourd'hui à 3 625% fin 2015
c'est c'est pas rendre service au pays
que de dire avec les efforts que l'on a
demandé à tout le monde on y reviendra
sur les collectivités territoriales avec
les efforts demandés à tout le monde de
ne pas reconnaître que le bébé que le
déficit public a baissé
qu'on dise qu'il n'a pas suffisamment
baissé qu'on n'a peut-être pas pris les
bons outils pour le faire baisser
c'est son droit j'allais dire se dévoile
et démocratique veut dire des
contrevérités pareil pour moi c'est
chaud quand on sera prêt pour ça alors
la question donc eh ben on la formule à
nouveau parce que l eau est ce qu'il va
y avoir une nouvelle baisse d'impôts en
2017 après celle de 2015 2016 alors que
vous pouvez nous l'annoncer et faisable
est ce que présente plus l'oracle de
bercy
le président de la république a été très
clair présentant au public a dit nous
verrons en fonction des marges qui
seront devant nous quels seront les
possibilités pour avoir des baisses
d'impôts l'année prochaine nous
souhaitons ces baisses d'impôt nous
avons commencé vous avez eu la
gentillesse l'objectivité de rappeler
qu'effectivement ça a été le cas en 2015
les prélèvements obligatoires dire
l'ensemble de ce que le l'état en tous
cas les collectivités publiques
demandent comme contribution ont baissé
entre raid sanglant les champions
d'europe
oui m'enfin ils ont baissé on reste
aussi le champion d'europe sur un
certain nombre de prestations que l'on
fournit à nos concitoyens ont parlé de
la santé on peut parler de la retraite
c'est un mec mais la peau l'impôt sur le
revenu puisque vous en parlez c'est le
moment des déclarations d'impôts les
français effectivement sont concernés
sur l'impôt qui v ille et touche plus
laisser passer pas d'ailleurs le plus
important pour le pays nous sommes
maintenant fin du mois de mai d'une
année budgétaire
aujourd'hui comment voulez-vous alors
même que les français sont seulement en
train de remplir leur déclaration
d'impôts que je sache que nous sachions
à bercy avec nos équipes
combien les recettes de l'état vont être
pour cette année en cours une année qui
est à peine commencée les recettes de
tva sur un précédent d'annoncer des
baisses d'impôts donc vous parce que
nous avions deux vous aurez tisserand
mais non je suis prudent on peut pas
entendre des prévisions de croissance
confirmée par le fmi à l'année dernière
à la même époque on diriger votre
prévision de croissance ne sera pas
atteinte il va vous manquer 10 milliards
de recettes
à la fin de l'année il a manqué 0
milliards de recettes elles ont été
conformes à nos prévisions il est prévu
une version plus optimistes comme le
président de la république lui a
clairement indiqué clairement indiqué
nous en sommes s'expliquer avec lui
michel s'appelle mois entre autres avec
le premier ministre a clairement indiqué
que nous ferons le point à fin du mois
de juin au début du mois de juillet
lorsque
or en affiner nos prévisions de recettes
pour cette année et qu'en fonction
effectivement des tendances qui seront
confirmées ou infirmées en fonction de
l'évolution de nos recettes en fonction
des taux d'intérêt en fonction de la
croissance qui sera constaté aujourd'hui
on connaît les résultats du premier
trimestre et encore 14 juillet je suis
patient sera le 14 juillet le 13 ou le
au début du mois de septembre la loi de
finances sera présenté au conseil des
ministres
comme tous les ans à la fin du mois de
septembre mais ça aura quand même le
dernier mercato général écoutez si les
marges apparaissent se confirme et
peuvent se quantifier on verra sous
quelle forme je veux dire est ce que ça
veut dire que les différentes les
nouvelles dépenses que vous avez annoncé
depuis janvier qui sont intervenus comme
comme disait sénateur très très très
rapidement après le vote de la loi de
finances rectificative de fin d'année
est ce que ça veut dire qu'elles ont été
tellement importante que finalement la
fameuse redistribution par le françois
hollande depuis un an ou deux et déjà
fait en fin de cette manière et que
finalement ce n'est plus par l'impôt que
vous allez la poursuivre pour suivre
éventuellement mais ce que ce que vous
oubliez les uns des autres c'est que les
baisses d'impôts par exemple pour les
entreprises elles ont déjà eu lieu là le
1er avril les cotisations sociales tout
le monde l'a oublié et mes cotisations
sociales des employeurs ont baissé de
pour pour près de 4 milliards d'euros en
mai le chef de l'état libyen après les
entreprises les ménages mais les ménages
il ya eu des mesures en faveur des
ménages on les a clairement rappelé mais
aujourd'hui nous avons annoncé 4
milliards effectivement de dépenses
supplémentaires et il ne pas les peler
les mettre en oeuvre ces mesures
fallait-il ne pas répondre à la crise
agricole avec près de 900 millions
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires sur
des réductions de cotisations aux
agriculteurs fallait-il ne pas mettre en
oeuvre la prime à l embauche qui marche
bien
le plan de formation qui va nous coûter
avec la prime à l'embauché autour de 2
milliards doré était n'a pas en année
lunaire qui était alignée
ne parurent comme les urines
électoralisme était-il les augmenter
laissons ceux qui contestent ces mesures
à porter la critique les points dadis a
été bloqué pendant cinq ans cinq ans
c'est beaucoup d'efforts qui a été
demandé un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires même si nous avons pas
mais regardez la campagne hors catégorie
des mesures demandées au ministère ils
ont supprimé des fonctionnaires une
baisse des effectifs de 2 % c'est aussi
la conséquence de l'augmentation du
poids nadil c'est pas nouveau ça julien
nous nous avons une stabilité globale
nous avions une stabilité globale de nos
effectifs durant les trois premières
années de la législature avec une
augmentation des enseignants une hausse
du nombre d'enseignants avec une
augmentation du nombre de policiers avec
une augmentation du nombre de personnels
de la justice
nous avons donc baisser nos
fonctionnaires dans un salon de services
à bercy dans service des finances
publiques nous supprimions environ 2000
postes tous les ans c'est la masse
salariale des fonctionnaires
il n'y a pas une baisse de la masse
salariale a augmenté de 0 9% j'observe
au passage que ces chiffres le plus
faible depuis des années à l'augmenter
traditionnellement de 1 5%
elle n'a augmenté si je veux dire que de
0 9%
donc il ya eu une maîtrise en tout cas
même c'est pas une baisse de la masse
salariale
parce qu'il ya quand même la promotion
et les fonctionnaires qui conduisent
naturellement même si points à 10 et
gelé à une augmentation de revenus
donc ces 4 milliards c'est ce que nous
avions fait l'année dernière année
dernière en cours d'année on a vu des
mesures sur la sécurité on avait aidé
mais sûrement et mais l'opposition de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
une peste ce chiffre et parle de plus
notre plutôt de 6 milliards sinon ça il
a reconnu que ses troupes et gt gt à la
commission des finances il ajoute des
dépenses de 2016 à des dépenses de 2017
je reviens à la baisse d'impôts hérités
caire parce qu'en fait vous êtes coincé
par le chef de l'état il a annoncé qu'il
y aurait est ce que j'ai l'air d'être
quoi écouter
lancé par le chef de l'état à partir ont
ils annoncé
en tout cas n'ait pas l'air très javel
après dimanche je suis à l'émission et
puis c'est une région c'est de réduire
les déficits qu'il ya deux moyens de
réduire les déficits c'est d'augmenter
les recettes par des augmentations
d'impôts il n'en est pas question
à rome sur une stratégie de réduction
des impôts nous l'avons déjà fait et
nous continuerons à le faire mais si
nous n'arrivons pas à contenir les
dépenses de façon suffisante
on ne pourra pas réduire les impôts et
réduire le déficit en même temps mais
j'observe c'est très important qu'en
2015 c'est ce que nous avons fait en
2015 nous avons réduit le déficit public
et nous avons réduit les prélèvements
obligatoires donc les impôts
nous l'avons fait en 2015 et nous avions
des dépenses supplémentaires notamment
sur les questions de développement
l'euro est toujours très bas et le taux
d'intérêt c'est nous préférons que d'un
moment c'est pas pour rien au hasard non
plus dresser vous pouvez le faire grâce
est quand même resté la crise que vous
avez déjà cheval ont estimé une masse en
milliards de ca poirier c'est trop tôt
et fonda au total mais je sais que c'est
bien j'ai commencé par nous parler de
l'oracle je dis je il faut toujours
garder de l'humilité par rapport aux
prévisions
regardez l'insee a révisé à la hausse la
croissance de 2014 ou yahiaoui jour
quinze jours et elle n'a pas révisé de
d'un petit peu là multiplié par trois
avec le recul vous rendez compte
et aujourd'hui vous me demandez moi
d'avoir croix de bois croix de fer une
prévision de croissance nickel pour 2010
est intangible que vous parlez de 7,7
prévient enfin de cette croissance
révisée par l'insee
qu'est ce que ça dit delà de la valeur
qu'on te donner aux statistiques et de
deux de ces chiffres qu'on donne chaque
année y compris d'ailleurs celui déficit
voilà les statistiques j'ai tendance à
penser que lorsqu elle repose sur des
constats c'est à dire sur le passé sont
plutôt fiables
même si m6 a eu quelques révisions
effectivement ils paraissent un peu
surprenant je rappelle que lindsay un
comptable national indépendant reconnu
par eurostat
mission comme étant indépendant c'est
pas le gouvernement c'est vraiment
l'insee je peux vous dire d'ailleurs
qu'il ya une séparation extrêmement
fortes au moment où l'insee joue son
rôle de comptable national
fermons cette parenthèse par contre pour
l'avenir chacun comprendra que les
prévisions pour l'avenir dépendent bien
entendu de ce qui se passe chez nous des
pentes parfois vous l'avez rappelé de ce
qui se passe dans le contexte taux
d'intérêt prix du pétrole croissance
mondiale commerce mondial dépend aussi
de la situation internationale un
conflit par exemple peut avoir des
conséquences économiques importantes y
compris chez nous et donc il faut
toujours avoir une crainte n nourris
venant à plus long terme à plus court
terme
sept prix nobel vous l'avez vu dénoncent
la suppression de 200 millions d'euros
de crédits un coup de massue distille un
suicide scientifiques et industriels
alors que vous avez défendu
monsieur le ministre d'attractivité de
la france il ya un instant alors vous m
tu es donc l'attractivité et le
dynamisme de la france en danger
notamment c'est ce que dit jean jouzel
du giec recherche est extrêmement
compétitive faut bien comprendre ça
disons il ya une compétition au niveau
international est effectivement à chaque
fois qu'on prend du retard et bien je
crois qu'on ne le rattrape paris cette
coupe budgétaire allemand risque de
moments de briser cette dynamique qui
est en place actuellement qui est
relativement disons normal pour un pays
comme la france dont on aimerait qu'elle
soit plus disons plus forte main tout
cas pas plus faibles comme celle qu'on
nous annonce aujourd'hui oui alors je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails des
chiffres c'est pas deux sens et 114
millions d'euros mais coupes budgétaires
c'est pas le bon terme
qu'est ce que l'on a fait en bonne
gestion des deniers publics
nous avons regardé quels étaient les
trésoreries des grands opérateurs de
recherche notamment le cnrs le ceva et
deux autres opérateurs
ces réserves budgétaires c'est
trésorerie budgétaire qui ne sont pas
actives et qui sont activés au moment
des dépenses étaient pour certaines
dentelle trop importante
et en fait de coupes budgétaires
d'accord avec vous en principe ils
investissaient que d'écouter les coupés
au moment où les besoins de décaissement
se feront il y aura les moyens
nécessaires parce que les programmes
d'investissements dans la recherche pour
pas des programmes qui se déclenchent du
jour au lendemain
joe des programmes qui sont programmés
et nous avons suivi très attentivement
la trésorerie de ces organismes ans
intéresse il ya plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros de trésorerie
est-ce qu'il serait aujourd'hui
compréhensible qu au moment où on
demande des efforts à l'ensemble des
acteurs publics
il y ait des réserves il y en a au cnrs
il y en a peu au ceva je le concède il y
à il ya un travail à poursuivre
approfondir je lui dis d'ailleurs la
commission des finances la semaine
dernière l'assemblée nationale par
contre je veux dire les trésoreries qui
ne sont pas mobilisés que ce soit pour
les organismes de recherche
que ce soit 1 chambre de commerce et
d'industrie ctk lundi l'anr que ce soit
dans les collectivités locales on encore
à tout à l'heure
mais il ya ce soit dans les organismes
hlm il y à un certain nombre de
trésorerie dormance que ça signer ça
aujourd'hui nous en avons besoin pour
pouvoir s qualité des chercheurs est ce
que ça signifie que à force de faire des
économies les et communion commencer en
2012 l on était quand même très
importante
on approche les autour des 60 milliards
si je me trompe pas quand même cinq ans
tué sur le quinquennat
est ce que ça veut dire qu'au bout d'un
moment on touche le dur au bout d'un
moment on touche des choses qui sont
aussi importantes que les budgets de la
recherche ont compris si c'est pour des
questions comptables une histoire de
trésorerie alors que justement le
président avait dit lui-même que c'était
des budgets qui serait complètement
sanctuariser qui est extrêmement petit
je répète le budget du plat mis en cause
sont les trésoreries mais moi je
souhaite bien du plaisir à ceux qui
aujourd'hui pattes les estrades main en
annonçant 100 milliards d'euros on en
parlera d'un creusement 100 milliards
d'euros en parlera des tirs le double de
ce que nous avons fait et à la suite de
ce que nous avons fait aujourd'hui
on a eu quelques difficultés avec la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale pour des économies d'un
virgule 1 milliard d'euros et
aujourd'hui les candidats
j'observe
la grands partis soient les candidats la
première à en parler en parler annonce
100 milliards d'euros d'économies quand
j'ai dit ça ou parlementaires de droite
et au président carrese notamment
certains ont commencé à regarder leurs
godasses comme j'ai l'habitude de pierre
thoretton oui parce que les économies
tout le monde et réclament les français
les réclames la presse les réclames le
fmi les réclames le gouvernement les les
pousse les parlementaires les ventes
mais quand on les fait c'est toujours
chez les autres qu'il faut les faire et
bien aujourd'hui on entraîne l'ensemble
du pays
dans un mouvement d'économie une
question nous conduisons une question
sur les pressions sur google qui est
soupçonné de fraude fraude fiscale
également en france il ya une
perquisition du siège parisien ce matin
du du géant américain
on sait que ça fait suite à une plainte
de l'administration fiscale
est ce que le bras de fer là se durcit
avec avec google par le biais de la
justice
alors je vous remercie beaucoup de me
poser cette question le bras de fer il a
toujours été dur contrairement à ce qui
est dit parfois où ce que certains
peuvent penser légitimement nous sommes
un strap je suis astreint au secret
fiscal
je ne peux pas aujourd'hui vous dire
combien les cas elle dans quel délai
voyez quand même on sait que google ait
menacé le redressement d'un milliard
trois cents millions c'est vous qui le
dites c'est moi qui ai dit vous qui le
dites s'est pas démentie d'attendre on
sait que ça que je ne peux pas vous
démentir je vous donne un exemple à
l'offre
cinq entreprises multinationales l'année
dernière en 2015 ont fait l'objet de
redressements fiscaux et de pénalités
pour 3,3 milliards d'euros à cinq et à 5
seulement nous avons redressé 3,3
milliards d'euros de d'impôts et de
pénalités
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ce
gouvernement
et c'est pour le moins une nouveauté est
un gouvernement qui travaille sur les
questions de fiscalité qui poursuit un
certain nombre d'entreprises
nous ne faisons pas de publicité
aujourd'hui c'est le parquet nationaux
et financier mais vous avez vous avez
rappelé que c'était sur la place louis
sur la base mais plainte
d'ailleurs de la direction chez la
justice màj cela qu'il n'en faudrait
sont invités dans cette partie fermée où
seulement tant que ministre est ce que
vous seriez prêt à une transaction à mon
goût gueule
non il n'ya pas de transactions dans ce
pays
nous avons été sollicité plusieurs fois
et que ça s'est passé en bataille mais
vis à ses patients leur empreinte et
vous avez vu qu'elle a été le montant
des retraites espère initialement
beaucoup moins que la somme s p dans tel
âge et leur look et blanc sera en tout
cas c'est le fisc aujourd'hui qui a
notifié le redressement
si google souhaite google et d'autres
souhaitent aller au bout des procédures
isiro au bout des procédures mais nous
ne ferons pas de transactions sur ce
type de situation grave c'est clair et
net on va parler de politique maintenant
notamment avec michael zamit son camp
une question est ce que le prélèvement à
la source vraiment entrera en
application dans les délais indiqués
voulue par le chef de l'état puisque
dans l'impression que la machine se
grippe un peu voire pas du tout ma pas
de knauf
le texte a été finalisée je peux vous le
dire hier il a été transmis où il doit
être transmis aujourd'hui au conseil
d'état et nous serons donc en mesure de
présenter ce texte au parlement dans la
loi de finances de 2010 est comme nous
l'avons indiqué et donc nous sommes
prêts à vous êtes prévenus il ya
beaucoup de difficultés quand même
d'abord c'est une réforme qui met
vraiment la fille quand même de faire
c'est une réforme qui souhaitaient
attendu c'est une réforme vous qui dit
souvent qu'on est les champions du monde
et d'europe
c'est là nous sommes le seul pays
d'europe à ne pas pratiquer le problème
en agence
donc nous sommes prêts de révolte en
liga et le calendrier tout à fait connu
sept numéros de 8 à bien cette et 1er
janvier 2018
si dieu nous prête vie le prélèvement la
région sera font vite merci
laissez-le mais qu'elle abaisse donc de
plus vers cela arrive maintenant
monsieur et caire pour poser cette
question est ce que vous allez entendre
enfin le sos des collectivités locales
les maires de droite et de gauche vous
réclame vous le savez là encore des
marges de manoeuvre des comptes est
votre vision sur leur compte
c'était par exemple le cas il ya quinze
jours ici même à votre place dans leurs
tiroirs 3 - 2 gérard collomb le sénateur
maire socialiste de lyon on écoute ce
que me dit monsieur kert et alors là je
m'inscris en faux contre lui et je veux
dire qu'on peut mener un débat quand il
le veut aujourd'hui vous allez avoir une
baisse de l'investissement des
collectivités locales qui va être
relativement
horta et vous allez le voir dans les
deux années qui viennent
nous sommes cinquante neuf maires dans
ma communauté urbaine il peut les
prendre les uns après les autres
il y en aura aucun qui va lui dire que
c'est pas hyper compliqué de boucler un
budget bon à savoir mickaël michel
bourses américaines ont soit veut savoir
vous êtes trop débat avec gérard collomb
ah oui quand vous voulez ma vie très
organisé pour dire ce soir parce qu'elle
vous interpelle oui moi je peux lui
répondre dubi il le sait d'ailleurs
qu'est qu'est ce que j'ai dit qu'est ce
que je maintiens sur la situation
financière des collectivités
territoriales et des dotations de l'état
représentent un quart des recettes des
collectivités territoriales ce car nous
l'avons baissé de 8%
oui 2.2 je vous avais baisser les
dotations 8 imiter oui pour ça
représente pour le quart de leurs
recettes
une baisse significative 3,66 milliards
environ mais ça va le reste
le reste des recettes des collectivités
territoriales le recettes fiscales que
ce soit les impôts locaux que ce soit la
cvae pardon de ses mots sa technique
oui mais enfin ce sont des impôts que
paye toutes les entreprises cvae la
contribution foncière des entreprises
tous les saint bruno mutation des droits
d'intention dans ça vous va rapporter
ont augmenté sans variation des taux de
façon considérable pourquoi tout
simplement parce que les bases sont
révisés tous les ans pour certaines
d'entre elles et pour d'autres notamment
les dm théo les droits de mutation comme
vous l'évoquez meinau christian augmenté
vers le marché immobilier s'est décoincé
et donc quand on regarde l'ensemble de
leurs recettes elles n'ont pas baissé
elles ont augmenté de 1 70% pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
pris ce que vous avez dit c'est à dire
que les mesures que vous avez mis en
place et cette baisse des dotations pour
est-ce qu'il vous dise aujourd'hui c'est
une provocation on ne vous croit pas que
parce que ils sont été habitué à une
situation beaucoup plus confortable ce
que vous croyez que c'est facile pour
l'état de réunir les ministres et de
leur demander des efforts de réduction
de leurs effectifs de leurs moyens et
qu'ils ont été bloqués
d'avancé je pense que lorsque derek j
étais du local je crois connaître un peu
cette situation j'étais élue régionale
aussi il y a trois raisons pour
lesquelles l'investissement si je ne
conteste pas je lui ai dit d'ailleurs
lui-même écrit est en péril le non il
est pas en péril il a baissé alors ils
baissent systématiquement lorsqu'il ya
des renouvellements électoraux ce qui
était le cas généralement une baisse de
l'ordre de 8%
il a baissé de l'ordre de 11% c'est plus
que d'habitude c'est vrai plus que
d'habitude aussi parce que les équipes
ont quand même plus changer que
d'habitude notamment termes
d'orientation politique
deuxième raison l'incertitude sur un
seul nombre de textes qui sont venus à
être mis en oeuvre tardivement et nous
avons au gouvernement notre part de
responsabilité la fusion des régions a
mis du temps à se faire la paix la loi
carte des intercommunalités qui vient
d'être arrêté au 31 mars a mis du temps
à se faire
ça veut dire que des collectivités des
communes des intercommunalités qui ne
savait pas dans quelle configuration se
retrouver le lendemain avec quelles
compétences ont retardé ne vous leurrez
aujourd'hui maintenant ça suffit vous
investissez non je le redis aujourd'hui
regardez les collectivités locales
encore un chiffre des pauses
traditionnellement trésor 30 milliards
d'euros en fin d'année l'année dernière
c'était 34 c'est à dire 4 milliards de
plus que la veille contre tous contre
tous les élus de france de droite de
gauche sort alors comment expliquer ce
phénomène inédit vont chauffer sévère
d'abord je ne crois pas être seul
maintenant de deux collègues y compris
au gouvernement qui partagent cette
analyse moi c'est une analyse que je
donne mais si vous voulez baisser la
dépense publique vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que nous étions les champions
d'europe de la dépense publique mais
c'est par vagues et des statuts les
dépenses des collectivités territoriales
sont supérieures aux dépenses de l'état
vous faut l'avoir en tête ou à peu près
en tout cas équivalente
donc on peut pas imaginer pc la dépense
publique
si on ne baisse pas la dépense des
collectivités territoriales et la moins
identique d'habitude d'ailleurs c'est un
premier résultat
donc ça je suis prêt à la confrontation
aller confrontation vous êtes très
confrontation qui revient afin que tous
les élus
je suis pas l'habitude du congrès des
maires vous avez y aller au congrès des
maires non parce que je suis partant
mais julien dray qui va y aller c'est le
président de la république juste le mot
ce qu'il peut éviter la bronca du public
qui sera sur place
qu'est ce qu'il doit faire pour éviter
cette branche généralement quand on rend
visite à quelqu'un on arrive avec des
fleurs cadeaux à livre un cadeau et je
pense que l'on aura d'obliques fera
certain nombre d'annoncés au congrès des
maires sur la dgf la réforme de la dgf
le montant de la réduction de la
déchéance il
les dotations versées par l'état il y
aura des annonces du chef de l'état donc
tu veux mener le des personnes personne
non personne ne peut penser un seul
instant que le chef de l'état n'aura pas
un certain nombre de messages apportée
aux mères mais pas seulement mer des
messages des mesures oui m'enfin savez
les maires ne se contente pas de parole
qu'est ce qui pourrait arriver une
baisse étalée dans le temps et dans le
temps sur des dotations globales de
fonctionnement pour les territoires qu
on verrait merrill a lieu le 2 juin je
crois qu est-ce qu il serait pas grave
foncez vous imaginez mais vous
n'imaginez pas un seul instant que
certains états au budget d'abord
connaissent entièrement le discours du
président la république aura lieu dans
quelques jours et quand bien même il le
connaîtrai qui vous en face paris si des
détails
c'est en tous les cas vous apporter une
information il y aura donc des annonces
du chef de l'état devant le congrès des
maires de france ne recevront la semaine
prochaine avoir annoncé lundi la mfr va
quand même elles sont attendues elle
sourit beaucoup du françois baroin sera
neutre notre invité en tous les cas
quand l'information avait commencé à
chuter vous vous aviez démenti cela à
bercy comme un sur 90 des gestes pour
l'économie il ya plusieurs façons danon
plusieurs choses qui peuvent être fait
rentrer un peu dans le détail avait pas
trop on a bien compris le médecin enfin
vous ne me faites pas dire le contraire
parce que je vais dire ou de ce que j'ai
pu dire et en quelques mots il ya il ya
les dotations de l'état dont il faut
apprécier le rythme de la baisse est
aussi des mesures en faveur de
l'investissement que nous avons
déjà prises et qui à mon sens serait
également extrêmement utile merci pour
cette précision questions sur les
collectivités toujours est-ce qui va
payer le rsa les départements où c'est
l'état qui va prendre en charge parce
que on comprend plus visiblement ces
bisbilles ne vous comprenez pas pas vous
vous connaissez ces sujets le premier
ministre a clairement fait la
proposition au département de reprendre
en charge le paiement du rsa sur la base
de l'année précédente comme ça s'est
toujours fait quand il ya des transferts
de compétences ce qui représentera une
dépense supplémentaire pour l'état ou à
la verse une économie pour les
départements de l'ordre de 700 millions
d'euros et département souhaite qu'on
prenne comme référence des années
antérieures et officiers que le pr mais
au final la balle est dans le camp ces
jeux les départements non il y adhérer
des rencontres qui sont prévues dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines si les départements accepte
cette proposition ils ne payeront plus
le rsa ils économiseront 700 millions
d'euros c'est le saint graal mais le
singe ou non cette information est
connue et des publics
alors vous brûliez de parlé tout à
l'heure de programme de choc des
candidats à la primaire de droite pour
le budget notamment pour les
fonctionnaires écouter ce que disait il
ya quelques jours françois fillon lui il
propose une baisse importante du nombre
des fonctionnaires
bien bien supérieure aux 2% que vous
demandez aujourd'hui dans aux différents
ministères je propose de passer à 39
heures le temps de travail dans les
trois fonctions publiques
je reconnais que c'est évidemment un
projet ambitieux mais il ya pour moi
absolument fondamental pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que je veux supprimer la
durée légale du travail est renvoyé à la
négociation dans les entreprises pour
que la négociation dans les entreprises
se passe correctement il faut mieux que
la référence soit 39 heures plus tôt
qu'à 35 et donc si la fonction publique
et à 39 heures la référence sera à 39
heures la deuxième raison c'est que il
faut réduire les effectifs de la
fonction publique de façon très
importante et moi je propose de les
réduire de l'ordre de 500 mille
personnes dans les trois fonctions
publiques pendant les cinq années du
quinquennat
voilà l'un des traitements de choc pour
un pays en crise est peut-être une
solution impossible jeu et rien de mon
point de vue c'est impossible
ses cibles monsieur fillon peut dire ce
qu'il veut il a été promise de se payer
je crois pendant cinq ans dire des
choses pareilles c'est se faire plaisir
c'est peut-être faire plaisir à certains
mais c'est complètement impossible pour
cheveux jeudi deuxièmement monsieur
fillon d'y faire travailler 39 heures
mais il dit pas s'il paye 39 ou 35
heures
moi qui le disent lui dit aux gens qui
aujourd'hui je travaille 35 heures the
les traits 39 heures mais si c'est pour
le même salaire et le dit pas je ne sais
pas comment il va faire
autre élément sais pas monsieur fillon
sarkozy je crois qu'ils de 10% en parler
de la baisse de l'impôt
enfin il propose aussi d'imposer aux
collectivités territoriales ne pas de ne
plus embaucher au moment du départ en
retraite
comment il peut lui accorder mais
comment il peut le faire
la constitution dans notre pays donne la
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre des lois du
pays
je te vois que vous êtes toujours
aujourd'hui tout le monde est vent
debout contre une baisse des dotations
qui nient qu'ils laisseront qui mettrait
le pays laisse encore augmenter les
recettes de
des collectivités locales vous allez
leur dire qu'ils ne remplacent pas leurs
fonctionnaires de façon autoritaire
enfin ceci c'est une politique de
gribouille et cent mille fonctionnaires
à bercy nous sommes un des ministères
qui supprime le plus d'emplois du moins
dans la par exemple dans la direction
générale des finances publiques deux
mille 2000 et c'est difficile je voulais
je vous montre les lettres des maires
des sénateurs des députés
les républicains qui m'écrivent il ne
faut pas à tarbes ferme et à lagence
telle trésorerie ne faut pas à agen il
ne faut pas à bordeaux regroupant une
cinquantaine à promettre la rupture
alors ils vous promettent alors que nous
faisons 2000 suppressions d'emplois à
bercy il vous en promettent cent mille
par an mais souci était impossible vous
avez entendu le fmi encore aujourd'hui
on a parlé déjà tout à l'heure qui veut
dire que la situation de force brute
s'est améliorée bien entendu mais qu'il
fallait rationaliser sur les
fonctionnaires là aussi c'est ce que
propose françois fillon ce que vont
poser à juppé
mais nous faisons nous le faisons nous
avons décidé d'embaucher 10 mille
enseignants supplémentaires tous les ans
nous l'avons fait nous avons nous
demandé encore plus nous avons demandé
20 ans organisé l'embauchent de plus de
policiers de plusieurs gendarmes et nous
y avons été je vais dire en plus
encourager même contre un contenu de la
situation relativement au terrorisme
nous avions prévu de baisser les
effectifs dans l'armée nous y avons
renoncé contenu la pâte est nécessaire
mais vous dites aux effets mitraillé
dans les autres ministères
je voulais dit dg fipd ministère de
l'environnement d'autres organismes y
compris dans des organismes
d'enseignement
nous nous avons des des réductions de
personnels qui sont extrêmement
importantes que tout le monde trouve
insupportable respectons donc une
question d'actualité encore oui est-ce
qu'il faut une loi sur la rémunération
des patrons
oui et ça veut dire que c'est presque
une réponse réflexe que vous nous faites
non c'est ce que c'est ce que dit
emmanuel marolle aujourd'hui dans les
echos noah fut noah c'est de réponse
réflexe c'est à dire un problème une loi
mais moi je veux vous vous croyez qu
avant de répondre à votre question je
n'ai pas réfléchi premièrement
on a vu au travers d'exemples récents
que l'assemblée générale des
actionnaires n'est pas entendue
lorsqu'elle refuse une augmentation
scandaleuse excessive dix ans deux d'un
dirigeant d'entreprise
deuxièmement michel sapin premier
ministre ont clairement indiqué dans les
travaux actuellement en cours au moment
où on se parle à l'assemblée nationale
sur la loi sapin 2 il y aurait un
certain nombre d'amendements qui
donnerait plus de pouvoir aux
actionnaires pour éviter une noire ne
soient pas entendus
lorsqu'une loi hameaux et nous a
complètement tout cas la xsara il y aura
des passages dans la loi sapin qui vont
concerner cette question qu'à sion et
cartes 2017 ça approche à grands pas que
vous avez vu les sondages mais demain
ils mettront tout en haut
françois hollande tout en bas ça vous
inquiète non pas du tout pas du tout bon
jeu je dis pas l'oeil rivé au sondage se
voulait dit tout à l'heure avec moi je
suis secrétaire d'état depuis un peu
plus de deux ans c'est une
responsabilité
je veux pas donner un ton un peu plus
grave à notre entretien mai
ne pensez pas que les femmes les hommes
qui qui qui à qui on délègue le pouvoir
au nom du peuple français
ne croyez pas qu'ils ont parfois se pose
des questions sur la pertinence de la
décision
pour nous c'est extrêmement important
mais on ne le fait pas à l'aune de ce
qui va se passer au moment des
sélections suivantes c'était pas la
crise
mais si c'est quelque part votre
question parce que vous ne dites pas
alors macro et la hollande est là je
pense que françois le président a fait
un prix à son nom de responsabilité qui
nécessairement tenu à des équilibres
parfois des déceptions mais souvent des
des deux côtés responsabilité du
ministre de l'économie des cas là même
très bien en tous les cas on a bien
compris ce que vous venez de nous dire
quand vous devrez jauger de la
possibilité d'une baisse d'impôts en
2010 est à bercy vous ne le ferez pas en
pensant à la présidentielle c'est ce que
vous avez dit merci merci christine
vauchel
la semaine prochaine c'est françois
baroin le président de l'association des
maires de france justement équipe vous
avez beaucoup de sujets sur la table on
l'a vue qui sera notre invité bonsoir
elle pas qu'il oublie qu'il a été aussi
ce que trop d'états milices finances il
est moins excessif que certains bradent
vous avez vu sur la belle derrière pau 1
c'est vrai